foreign
the White House had a summit on stem
equity and inclusion really yeah
I
I watched it
I'm not sure why
this is stem stem yes which I'd never
seen before that acronym science
technology engineering math and medicine
and I guess it's because I subscribe to
science because
still feel like I need to and I don't
have an Institutional affiliation
because they've all gone completely
insane and so I got an announcement the
morning of hey we're doing this though
we're streaming the White House Summit
on stem Equity inclusion sponsored by
science I think okay let's go look
um so there's a lot to say but I just
and and you know it wasn't
it wasn't entirely ridiculous but
um because we have a lot of other things
that we're talking about today I will
restrict my comments to
to
quoting the president of Harvey Mudd
College whose name I have failed to
write down I apologize
um concludes her comment she's on one of
many panels and she concludes her
comments by so Harvey Mudd College is
one of the Claremont colleges it is a
very small very elite mostly engineering
school a stem School basically stem with
1M
um and uh you know advise as she claims
but it's true it advise for
undergraduates I think it's entirely
undergraduate I'm not sure about that
actually
um with the likes of MIT and Caltech uh
and uh
and she has some good things to say you
know she she talks about she and others
talk about the science of belonging
which sounds ridiculous but
um actually the idea that when you walk
into a classroom you shouldn't assume
that you belong because of your
demographics nor should you assume that
you don't belong busy for demographics
and the professor and everyone else in
the room should also not make those
assumptions and this is something that
we did without ever hearing of those
signs of belonging right in the
classroom but the idea that actually uh
College administrators and and faculty
are waking up to this you know decades
too late is at least something valuable
but she concludes her comments by saying
that on campus quote we also
continuously celebrate our cultural
value that every person every student
every faculty member every staff member
is responsible for the success of every
other person on campus
that struck me as something that could
just be
washed away ignored whatever okay do you
think you're doing good for people and
helping you know raise Everyone by not
you know making sure that no one is left
behind but
this strikes me as insane completely
insane completely anti-meritocratic
um
opposed to the idea of striving on your
own for instance
or being held responsible for your own
failures both of both of those things
are are weakened by the idea that you
no matter how good you are and or how to
how bad you are at whatever it is that
you're trying to do are responsible for
the success of everyone around you well
no you're not
you know it's funny because I remember
running into what is effectively a
different version of the same concept
and I remember running into it the first
time and it was as Evergreen was coming
apart and the claim
which again these claims they sound so
lovely right on first hearing but the
claim was that
Evergreen had a very serious problem
because people graduated with different
levels of capability and the idea was
that Evergreen was actually morally
required to ensure that everyone
graduated equally capable that's
Harrison Bergeron University right and I
heard that and I thought God there is
only one way to do that which is to
hobble those who are highly capable even
if they were right which they weren't
but even if they were right that these
disparities were the result
of unfairness right that was based on
sex or race or whatever even if they
were correct the idea that somebody who
enters College gifted in math right has
to basically
graduate with people who are either
brought up to their level which will be
impossible right because you can't take
somebody who has no math skill and bring
them up to the most capable person's
level or they will have to be sabotaged
for four years and and it's like they
don't
they don't first of all I'm not even
sure you know that they wouldn't come up
with you euphemisms for sabotage that of
course that would make them comfortable
but they don't they wouldn't even stop
upon hearing that and thinking oh yeah
now we can't have everybody graduate at
the same level because that means
ruining everybody's capacity that they
have right right the only level you can
equalize them all to is completely
incapable right that's the only
achievable place where that can happen
and you would be a fool
to go to a school to matriculate at a
school that had that as it's what does
she say
cultural value
that that would be an insane place to go
if they really are serious about it in
fact this is an argument that I made in
an email to our colleagues at Evergreen
I said you can't do this because nobody
you are effectively talking about
transferring
um educational well-being from certain
students to other students and the
students from whom you are transferring
it will simply not show up right why
people get your wish because the
standards will plummet well the
standards will plummet but the point is
you need all of those you know this was
not a rich College it needs a student
body willing to come and pay tuition and
you know to the extent that you're going
to drive those who are most capable off
you know it doesn't matter whether they
were capable for reasons that ultimately
come from unfairness you need them to
show up in order to have a college and
um well you also need the most capable
people to show up to
to be awesome to inspire to educate
others to provide foils for the faculty
to help bring the other students who
maybe maybe are less capable because
they've been disadvantaged and could
become more capable but they need to be
able to hear the conversation some
people are less capable because they're
just less capable
but a lot of people are less capable
because they've been disadvantaged but
they're not going to learn how to be
more capable if the only people they're
surrounded with are also not capable
like that's not how Learning Happens no
it's it's uh it's complete
um complete nonsense and the irony of
ironies in the case of our former
College
was that our former College was unique
in the fact that it was really well
designed to deal with high potential
people who hadn't been well served by
whatever system they came from right it
was well positioned awesome yeah they
really were and the
possibility to take people who had high
potential but hadn't been reached by
anybody and give them a Lifeline was a
mission that that Evergreen was uniquely
positioned to address that it's so
rewarding my God it's so amazing to you
know it at a moment when people are
claiming claiming that you know everyone
needs to be forced to succeed on you
know on the rubric that someone else has
created who maybe never even met a kid
right and then to actually be able to
to kind of like open up the world
to people who know that they're hungry
but don't know what they're hungry for
and maybe haven't even really ever had a
meal like here this is this is a bunch
of options you start making choices and
then maybe you start getting funneled
here or there but how extraordinary you
know as opposed to no just accept that
because the first 18 years of your life
you didn't get good education or you had
an unfortunate family situation or you
know or or you were malnourished or you
were you know any number of things well
then just give up now like no we need
institutions we need
more than functional outstanding
institutions that do not
uh discriminate against students who
didn't have advantages but have
extraordinary potential and Evergreen
was that place and I don't think there
is a place now that does it and it is it
is ideas like this that apparently I'd
forgotten actually that you would you
had heard it Evergreen I heard come from
the current president of Harvey Mudd
College an elite school as if this is an
honorable thing to be doing and it's not
it's it's the death of the University
yeah I mean it's you know it it's
cognitive communism and the point is
right look the problem with us try not
to use the word but yeah this is what it
is yeah the problem with all versions of
Communism is that it's an empty space
it's not a real place you can go right
it's not obvious that it would be
desirable if you could go there but it
doesn't work right it doesn't the
theoretical solution set you want to
have it taking taking a play a space but
it's not available in design space it is
inherently self unstable and doesn't
accomplish the things you need to
accomplish in order to make a
civilization work it doesn't accomplish
the things you need to make a university
work and so the question is all right in
light of the fact that communism is both
sucky and impossible right what else
might we do hey here's an idea how about
we increase everybody's capacity as much
as we can in the brief period of time we
have contact with them right wouldn't
that be cool if I may buy an allergy in
light of the fact that the vaccines are
neither safe nor effective what else
what else is
possible there's another possibility on
the table Yeah anybody anything
anybody and then you know the next thing
is overlooking Dr Corey Dr bhattachary
and all of these other every other folks
yeah no it's sucky and impossible yeah
but other than that like yes yeah
anything better like yes we got lots of
better does anybody have any other ideas
that we haven't yet declared evil you
know
[Music]
thank you